let's go to Steve in Los Angeles I Steve
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey that rate how are you better than I
deserve how can I help thank you thank
you
um well basically I'm new to your show
I've been listening to you for the last
three weeks and I mean I'm a normal
American citizen and normal I learned
with butanol sucks how can I get my wife
on the same boat as I I'm motivated and
I want to do this and I think I'm done
with baby step one but she doesn't seem
to be motivated I'm weird and totaled
that so three weeks ago you weren't
motivated but now you've started
listening to the show and you've gotten
motivated is that fair correct so what
do you think what the show did that
motivated you why Bhim broke for the
last ten years I've been to that was the
case three weeks ago but something when
you started listening to this broadcast
of me yakking something in that yakking
made you believe right yes yes what was
it well we make enough money to be out
of debt oh there you go then you never
thought of that before
no okay did you say that to her trying
trying to get the right wording on it
and say yes yes but she's not as
aggressive as I am I would like her to
be well three weeks ago you weren't
aggressive all right so what happened
was was that you got new information in
your brain that said that made you
believe it's called hope right you want
I mean I think we can do this not only
that I think we should do it because I
think we can get out of debt and I think
we should get out of that because if we
were out of debt we could do this we
could build wealth we could retire with
dignity we could give more whatever it
is it's running through your head right
so my point is this
you can't talk to someone about how to
do something before you talk to them
about
to do it and what was going through your
head is honey I don't know about you but
I'm tired this is you talking to your
wife I'm tired of being broke I'm tired
of being stressed and when I started
listening to this information it made me
believe that we could get out of debt if
we were willing to pay a price and it
made me but and I thought wow if we
didn't have any payments all the things
that we could do how wealthy could we
become we make too much money to be this
broke and you just start talking about
the why rather than walking in and going
hey I'm Alyssa this radio program when
you sell your car that does not work
okay
oh nope so you got to go another
direction with that and as you talk
about the why with anyone when you're
talking about them engaging in a reason
I mean why would you go to the gym and
huff and puff and strain and work
because you think it's going to cause
you to feel better and look better
that's why but you wouldn't just go
strain and huff and puff for no apparent
reason there has to be a why there has
to be a belief that I hope that if I
follow this diet and exercise plan I can
look like that and feel like that
instead of the way I look and feel today
you have to have that or you won't lift
you won't run you won't do your aerobics
you won't do whatever it is you need to
do in the gym too and you won't back off
from the food and it's hope the only way
you change behaviors you look up and say
hey doing the same thing over and over
and over again and expecting a different
result is the definition of insanity
we're not gonna live like this anymore I
am sick and tired of being sick and
tired we have to change something we've
been doing because if we keep doing what
we've been doing we're gonna we're gonna
be so broke that it's gonna be no fun
around here
it's already no fun around here we make
too much money to be this bro
and it's all about a reason to do stuff
and then you'll do what it takes then
you'll do what it takes it changes
everything there you gotta have a big
enough why that's how you do it